no i don't think biden should run for
re-election no because he's incompetent
no i don't i think he's delusional to
think that he's
capable mentally
of running again so he absolutely should
not
it would be embarrassing to party
embarrassing to
the public in general
[Music]
no i do not think he should run for
re-election and i think it's because of
his age
besides the fact that i think he may
have some medical issues that we're not
aware of
um he's built
a great team around him which really
helps him out
but no i don't think he
he should set up another democratic
candidate who can
take over where he's left off and be
central centrist
this group called the squad are off the
rails and
um
giving
the democratic party i think a bad name
i think he should uh
has he gotten everything done that i
wanted to see done
no
but
he's a long way
forward from where we're coming from
and
he get that second turn
i got his back i i don't think he should
and the main reason is his age
you know i think he's doing a pretty
good job right now considering his age
but
the fact that i'm getting older myself i
know how it is you know you forget your
words and you know your memory's not as
good so i think we need someone a little
stronger a little younger i really don't
get into politics but from what i see
he reminds me of someone has dementia no
i don't think he should run
but if he does decide to run i would
vote for him but i think he should give
the opportunity to his vice president at
this point
as a minority black woman
to run and i think she would win uh it
depends upon who
else is available
certainly
i would choose him over any
current front runner from the republican
party